what is and isn't wrong with Islam
that's the question before us today
since 2001 for obvious reasons almost
everything about Islam has been
criticized it's been presented as
hostile to progress anti-democratic
Theocratic patriarchical
misogynistic Draconian in its
punishments etc etc is that then what's
wrong with Islam I'm here to argue no
none of those are the reasons why
non-muslims should be wary of Islam why
because they are all intra
civilizational not inter civilizational
that is they are all things that Muslims
do to and amongst each other they do not
involve the non-muslim what care I of
Muslim societies agreed to say chopping
off the hands of Thieves or whipping
adulterers or strictly segregating the
Sexes if anything focusing on these many
issues that do not affect the non-muslim
creates confusion concerning those truly
problematic aspects of Islam that do
affect the so-called infidel
once we take a step back and distinguish
between those many doctrines that affect
Muslim Society alone and those that
extend to and affect western or
non-muslim peoples in general three
interrelated doctrines come into shark
play they are one hate for the Infidel
that is constant spiritual or
metaphysical hostility against all
non-muslims such hate naturally
manifests itself as to Jihad that is
physical hostility against and whenever
and wherever possible attempts to
subjugate the non-muslim finally
successful jihads beget three vitude the
degrading position that all non-muslims
who refuse to Forfeit the religion who
refuse to Forfeit the religious freedom
by converting to the Victor's Creed must
live under in an Islamic State in
regards to the first problem there's no
doubt that mainstream Islam Advocates
the separation of Muslims from
non-muslims Believers from infidels
clean from unclean according to the
doctrine of alw
in Arabic which can be translated as
loyalty and enmity or more simply love
and hate Quran 551 warns Muslims against
quote taking the Jews and Christians as
friends and allies whoever among you
takes them for friends and allies he is
surely one of them unquote that is he
too becomes an Infidel or a cfer the
worst human classification in Islam
there are many other Quran verses such
as this including 328 489
4144 554 640 92 23 they all have the
same divisive message 58:22 simply tells
Muslims to not befriend non-muslims even
if they are their fathers Sons brothers
or kin that's a direct quote but it gets
worse the Quran calls on Muslims to have
enmity hatred for non-muslims quote we
Muslims renounce you non-muslims enmity
and hate shall Forever Reign between us
till you believe in Allah alone that's
Quran 64 as the Islamic state has
explained in an un Ambiguously titled
article why we hate you and why we fight
you the first reason they gave is quote
we hate you first and foremost because
you are disbelievers infidels unquote
such enmity for non-muslims is
fundamentally responsible for the
metaphysical or spiritual clash between
Islam and the West add to the enmity the
fact that Muslims are permitted to lie
to non-muslims including by feigning
loyalty or friendship in the context of
the doctrines of tea and others and it
becomes apparent how dangerous the
doctrine of or love and hate becomes the
second aspect is Jihad war on
non-muslims for no lesser reason than
that they are non-muslims this is the
physical manifestation or the
realization of enmity for infidels not
only is it of course natural to attack
and seek to subjugate Those whom one is
Brad on hating but the doctrine of jihad
including to spread and enforce Sharia
around the world is part and parcel of
Islam it's no less codified than Islam's
Five Pillars as reflected by many Quran
verses such as Quran
9:29 fight those among the people of the
book which means primarily Christians
and Jews who do not believe in Allah nor
the last day nor forbid what Allah and
his messenger have forbidden nor embrace
the religion of Truth meaning Islam
until they pay jizya with willing
submission and feel themselves utterly
subdued or in the words of the
Encyclopedia of Islam's entry for Jihad
the quote spread of Islam by arm arms is
a religious Duty upon Muslims in general
Jihad must continue to be done until the
whole world is under the rule of Islam
Islam must completely be made over
before the doctrine of jihad can be
eliminated but as infidels are to be
hated per se and not merely in the
context of jihad the the ability of
which to prosecute is often curtailed by
circumstances the hostility continues
even after the cessation of successful
jihads unlike other conquerors that
generally permit the conquered to go on
unmolested so long as they do not
challenge the new order some conquerors
even try to appease and win over their
new subjects whenever and wherever Islam
has conquered that old metaphysical
hostility which fueled the Jihad remains
to gloat in triumph over the over the
subject infidels thus not only must the
latter the infidels the zies pay a
special tax jizya as we saw in Quran 929
and embrace a subordinate position and
follow number of debilitations they must
also be reminded and made to feel
inferior and despised including as a way
to inspire them to convert to the true
Faith so it's a bit of altruism as the
Islamic State explained in the
aforementioned article regardless of any
and all appeasement offered by the
non-muslim including submitting to
becoming AI quote we would continue to
hate you because our primary reason for
hating you will not cease to exist until
you Embrace Islam even if you were to
pay jizya and live under the authority
of Islam and humiliation we would
continue to hate you unquote the reason
for that is the first reason we saw the
enmity the hatred that the Quran
commands so in this third sense either
Which Way Islam wins if the non-muslim
continues in his faith if he remains as
a Christian for example the Muslims
continue to pray off him if on the other
hand the non-muslim eventually
surrenders to Islam and becomes a Muslim
then the umah gains a new recruit with
death as the penalty should he later
entertain second thoughts and choose to
apostas eyesee so there is the three and
I would argue only three Islamic
doctrines that non-muslims should really
concern themselves about they are to
reiterate hate for Jihad against and
theud of non-muslims none of these are
products of interpretation by the way
they are all unequivocally grounded in
Islamic law they're not open to debate
and they are they are the way Muslims
have done things in the past and in the
present whenever circumstances have
permitted at least it's these three
doctrines that non-muslims everywhere
should be dialoging with Muslims about
all right let me know if you agree or
disagree with my assessment in the
comments I'll be interested to see
including if there are any Muslims out
there bye